[Musique]
la fête s'est bien passé génial jamais
l'homme portait agi d'être femme en
laine presse et il boit
je m'appelle ciment et je suis comme toi
j'ai une famille normale des amis
géniaux un lycée banal
qu'est ce que tu fais pas de textos dans
les couloirs je ne peux pas laisser mes
étudiants allaient sur kindle c'est mon
domaine
j'ai une vie parfaitement normal sauf
que j'ai un énorme secret de mousse
salut nouveau poste
je parle de l'école
cher blue je suis comme toi mais
personne c'est que je suis gay chelsea
man c'est bon de savoir qu'un autre
garçon lisse et partage le même secret
quand est-ce que tu l'as eu cher blue il
ya une série de petites choses comme ma
première petite amie et je crois qu'ils
amoureuse de toi je reviens ça n'a pas
été mon heure de gloire je vous tends à
parler à quelqu'un ment blue
j'en ai parlé à personne quoi qu'on en
dise révéler aux autres ce qu'on est et
terrifiant habits celle la plus sexy que
j'ai jamais mais c'est pas vraiment mon
genre
pas parce que les noirs j'adore les
femmes noires enfin pas comme tu adores
toutes les femmes gèrent blue c'est très
injuste que seuls les gains doivent
faire leur coming out
imagine un peu il faut que je vous dise
quelque chose je suis hétéro j'aime les
filles quoi tu veux ma mort j'ai mis mes
rêves
on regarde tout de suite son ordinateur
quelqu'un a publié le 10 mai sur le blog
du lycée je regrette si moi je peux plus
continuer
[Musique]
c'est moi qui suis censée décider où
quand comment et qui le sait comment je
dois dire c'est quelque chose qui
m'appartient
c'est le genre de personne qui est
destiné mais tellement une personne qui
ça pourrait le devenir si je sentais
retenir sa respiration
tu es toujours toi simon
tu as déjà été amoureux je sais pas je
crois
cher blue je ne sais peut-être nous
tournons ni à quoi tu ressembles mais je
veux trouver
j'en peux plus de vivre dans un monde je
peux pas être qui je suis sorti avec moi
parce que tu trouves que je ressemble à
un garçon en fait j'ai rempli avec toi
parce que tu ne ressembles par agassa
d'accord merci dorian